for the phillies it'll be matt moore
making his debut moore who spent last
season in japan trying to re-establish
himself won the job as the fourth
starter in spring training with a strong
spring and he'll go to the mound tonight
for the phillies field leading off
live all left field
it's fairly deep but it's playable for
mccutchen
toward the end of the battle
and one out here in the first here comes
francisco lindor
wearing not only his conventional
and omnipresent smile
but the number 12
and also he prompts the reaction you
hear in the background and the phillies
fans they'll be booing this guy for a
long time
[Applause]
debut punches out two out nobody on and
michael conforto coming up and a swing
and a miss
he got it with a 93 mile an hour
fastball two strikeouts and matt moore's
debut now jacob degrom makes his debut
for the 2021 new york mets it's the
third straight year that jacob is the
mets opening day starter andrew
mccutchen leads off now the 2-2 to
mccutcheon on the way swung out and
missed strike three kept a 99-mile an
hour heater away and the grom has struck
out his first batter so one up one down
reese hoskins coming up that's it to
center field by hoskins d back goes
pillar on the track looking up and it's
off the top of the wall in play hoskins
racing for third the relay throw to
third they may get him and hoskins is
out
reece hoskins hitting one off the top of
the fence in right center field and
trying to leg out a triple which is not
his forte and he's thrown out on a
terrific relay yes from jeff mcneil
excellent fundies here
it's all about the things you work on in
spring training all your fundamentals
the grammar generally does not walk many
as walk harper it brings up the catcher
jt real muto harper runs the pitch swung
on and missed strike three got him with
a fast ball and that retires the side
the hardest pitch to grab through in the
first inning at 101 miles an hour
punches out real muto pete alonso will
lead off against the lefty matt moore
who looked really good striking out two
and a one two three first swing gonna
miss at 89. the cutter gives him his
third strikeout kd davis is coming up
swinging a foul tip that's strikeout
number four for matt moore and matt
moore
has retired five in a row the last four
by strikeouts to get started still one
out and one on and now gene segura who
tormented the mets all season last year
hits one toward the middle flag by
lindor the turn by mcneil double play
side retired
francisco lindor shooting behind the
back to start the 6-4-3 to get to grom
through the second
and francisco lindor draws a two-while
walk so
michael conforto has always worn out
philly's pitching will have a chance
here with the bases loaded and two outs
in this scoreless game ground ball right
side segora is there he's got it throws
to first in time
and the inning is over matt moore works
out of a bases loaded jab now the mets
have runners on first and third chance
for james mccann to get the bets on the
board and he lines one into left field
our base hit and the mets have their
first run of the season
james mccann first pitch swinging drives
home pete alonso his first hit his first
rbi is a met and mccann gives the mets a
one-nothing lead paisley
misjudging that ball in center field
turned that into an adventure nimmo gets
himself a pop fly hit and the bases are
loaded so now to ground bats with the
bases loaded jake had an infield hit his
first time
loops one shallow left and that's going
to fall for a base hit davis is in
degrom with his second hit of the night
two nothing new york haven't hit in two
years
who cares two for two and that's going
to be it for matt moore brandon kinsler
the veteran will come in for the
phillies the mets still have the bases
loaded one out
stop could be two dede the second for
one segura back over to first in time
a six four three double play
side is retired limited to the damage
now two out of two on here's mcneil
swung at the first pitch both times
ground ball right side he's had three
pitches
and he's retired on all three jacob
degrom who almost predictably has not
been vintage degrom sharp after the long
long layoff he goes right back to the
slider mccann fishes it out from between
his feet
and they complete the strikeout that's
five tonight for degrom
hazley pops it up
davis tracking it
two out two out of nobody on and now
matt joyce will pinch it for the fills
and joyce pops up the first pitch he
sees another chance for jd
and the side retired
nine pitching for degrom he's thrown
five scoreless just routine excellence
for degrom so far tonight now he starts
his third tour of the batting order
against andrew mccutchen and the slider
hit on the ground to lindor
and mccutchen retired one out jake's now
retired seven in a row as he settles
into a nice groove
and he struck him out with the slider
number six for degrom as he gets hoskins
for the second out and jacob degrom now
has really settled in he's retired eight
in a row
and with a two to nothing lead two out
nobody on in the sixth they'll face
bryce harper playing gonna miss strike
three the seventh strikeout for degrom
100 miles an hour on that pitch and the
phillies go in order miguel castro will
pick it up for jacob to grime as we go
to the bottom of the seventh grounded
down to alonso he makes the diving stop
side retired that's the third
sparkling play in the field by the mets
miguel castro tosses the scoreless
inning luke will make his mets debut
in a pressure cooker
brought in to face bryce harper with the
bases loaded and one out of the miss
protecting a two-nothing lead in the
eighth and it hits him that's going to
force it a run it's a 2-1 ball game the
bases remain loaded for jt real muto
ground ball toward the hole into left
field to base it we're tied at two
here in the bottom of the eighth inning
the phillies have tied this ball game up
into a piece with one out and the base
is loaded it is
alec bowm and the pitch to him bouncer
toward third g or may has it he's coming
home and his
throat
scores here comes harper he'll score the
phillies take the lead
put the ball and play and good things
happen the phillies have scored four
runs here in the eighth inning and lead
four to two
jose alvarado is going to try to close
it out bay sits by pilar and lindor have
set the stage for conforto the mets
squirming their way back into this game
in the top of the ninth lines one to
right sinking fast harper coming on
can't make the catch
pillar scores lyndorn a third
it's five to three and the tying runs
are on base with alonso coming up
out to right field
harper's going back toward the
scoreboard he's got room and he makes
the catch and the ball game is over
and for the fourth time in franchise
history
the phillies begin a season with a 4-0
record